[Music]
you guys can't be good it's no way
that's good news
a bridal wear nose
did you like their huge white staring
stupidly eat people
let's never start the battling me a
little bit
[Music]
as a black mamba okay trust one another
and never blink never blink huh you guys
I think it's a staring contest lately
it's talking about think about it never
blink guys who's good at staring and not
blinking I'm amazing at it then this is
your moment
[Music]
just say when
[Music]
need you to follow me and do exactly as
I say
let's move oh my god you guys I am so
stoked you are here you have no idea so
stoked thanks against the wall this game
sucks
watch your step in here stay off the
white bricks
[Music]
who you who are you who's she how are
you guys having what the hell
you know Spencer position lungi you pick
a character and then you're that person
in the game should we play
[Applause]
my god fridge yeah I'm fridge who are
you
me Spencer Martha yeah
I think we got sucked into the game and
we've all become the avatars we chose so
that means Bethany I'm an overweight
middle-aged man this can't actually be
happening guys how are we gonna get home
this is a video game which means we all
have special skills
[Music]
strength fearless speed
smoldering intensity damn that is a man
right there I hate this game
if we don't want to get stuck in Jumanji
we have to help each other
maybe we're all watch metal game machine
get in there go safer I'm not getting in
there okay I'm still an old fat guy
right I'm afraid so
have to warn you I think I'm a very
strong puncher
[Music]
what is it
don't let this new body get your butt
whooped I'd like to see you try
[Music]